The joe rogan experience when I was,
when you were talking about,
uh,
to change the subject a little bit when
you were talking about being honest and
crazy.
I had a great acting teacher,
I think I can say his name because he
actually talks about it and he's a really
good teacher.
He was a medic in Vietnam for two tours.
He's seen everything,
you know,
and he was like one of the first people
that somebody said to him in class,
you know,
he's take class from seven to 12.
I'll say it,
cause I love him.
His name is Richard Lawson is a really
special guy and he's got to Kuwait acting
class.
And he said,
uh,
somebody said,
I never seen you yawn.
And he goes,
yeah,
because I don't put my
attention on myself.
I put my attention out there.
I'm not thinking about being tired.
I don't focus on the fatigue.
And they were like,
what do you mean?
He goes,
I learned in Vietnam
watching when a Viet Cong,
when an American would get shot,
a lot of times they'd go into shock.
When you get shot you go,
oh my God,
I get shot.
And a lot of the time what goes,
what causes you to go into shock is
also a notion that you get shot in your
heart starts beating really fast cause
you're terrified because you might die.
I mean you,
you go into that notion,
the Vietcong,
they get shot in these horrific injuries
and you could still interrogate them
cause they'd be putting
their attention out there.
They would immediately start focusing and
their whole way of thinking anyway was
they were a leaf on a tree.
They weren't the tree.
So for whatever reason they
wouldn't go into shock as quickly.
They would immediately
put their attention on,
you know,
something in front of them.
So they weren't focusing on the wound.
And he said he used to see that when
he was a medic taking care of people.
And he saw such a fundamental striking
difference in the mindset between the
Vietcong and an American Gi.
And he was so impressed with their ability
to focus on anything but themselves.
They were not part of this equation.
They were a very small part of the
equation that he used it in his own life.
You know,
he,
he would use this idea of
he was tired or you know,
feeling sick that he would just literally
put his mind over there off himself,
take himself out of the and actually
watch himself move through what he had to
get done.
I bet you probably get a lot more energy
out of just doing that then opposed to
like festering on the idea that
you're tired of the course,
which is,
I always found that the things that I'd
just test the most and other people are
the things I'm terrified of seeing in
myself and the person who doesn't know how
to like push through shit and
get things done and just come on,
come on,
get up,
just do it.
Get the done,
get it done,
get it.
I'm not terrified of being that guy.
I'm terrified and not getting
shit done and you know,
and it forces me to find it
to be gross and other people,
you know?
Right.
It's like one of the things that scares
me about them taking wrestling out of
the Olympics.
Oh,
that's the worst.
It's crazy.
All the sport in the Olympics,
it's and the fact that it's
not even in every high school.
I think there's some real lessons to be
learned that a lot of people are never
going to learn and those lessons are
how to get through difficult shit,
how to get through the physical difficult
chicken and doing things physical,
which a lot of people were avoiding.
You get a more balanced mastery of your
own mind and that's a fucking important
aspect of being the human being and a
lot of people are skipping that step.
A lot of people are skipping that stuff.
I agree.
It can.
It can fuck you in the long run,
man.
It can give you the extra push
toward saying something stupid.
It can give you the extra bad energy to
take a left turn and I'll look to get
good at anything.
You know?
Let's take wrestling or
Jujitsu as an example.
If you're you,
if you want to get good,
you better work at what you're bad at.
You better work at the things,
you're bad at it.
You can't go in there and tap people out
with the stuff that you constantly know
cause the guys that are working on the
stuff they're not good at are going to
surpass you.
[inaudible] you just
learned that the hard way.
If you,
if you're not careful and I
think everything is that way,
you know you better,
you better work at what you are
the and you gain a lot of it.
A lot of that times I'll tell you,
you know,
hey you better music better
than musical instrument.
Learn how to do something.
What I like about doing,
playing the drums,
I got to learn how to do four different
things with which each limb it's really
difficult to do.
I gain a lot from just the practice and
the stretch of trying to learn how to be
a,
have all four limbs doing
something independent.
That's,
that's really interesting to me.
It actually changes my whole mindset.
I actually approach things very
differently for the rest of my day.
It's really weird.
I can't explain how or define how,
but it does make a difference.
I think when you take on new activities,
your mind,
when it starts concentrating
on some new thing,
whether it's playing the drums or a new
game you're trying to master whatever
the fuck it is.
When your mind gets really enthusiastic
about things and starts trying to figure
things out and working towards
and achieving like little goals,
you get invigorated.
Yeah.
It's this feeling of invigoration whenever
your pursue anything that you find to
be fun.
Anything that you find to be stimulating,
but the real thing is like everybody's
idea of what stimulating is different.
It just is thanking God and the real
problem is like that poor kid is fucking
dad.
Keeps pushed him into football
and he really wants to suck.
Cock a dance.
You know?
I mean Dan probably be the best
dancing cock sucker a long time.
We,
Billy Elliot,
Remember Billy Elliot?
It's like ballet.
He's do bought license.
I didn't see the movie.
Billy Elliot.
I'm a man.
Craig from an actual man.
That's what they need.
Baby grinder kits for kid Grindr.
No,
he comes from a coal mine.
I didn't even know what bill custom,
a coal mining family,
and the guy's like this hard ass
coal miner in the north of England,
like Manchester in this movie,
but just an English movie from Manchester
and the kid wants to be a valid
independent movie.
Uh,
no,
it's really popular that,
but he wants to be a ballet dancer.
He's an amazing ballet dancer.
He's an incredible dancer.
And his father's like Bali,
Bali,
like he can't believe it.
He's so angry.
He's like,
Bali,
my son's going to do follow my,
you know,
and it's just a disaster for him.
But that's what he is.
He's a fucking ballet dancer.
That's a great movie.
You got to find out what you grow,
what you groove is.
Yeah.
What's your groove?
Is it playing the drums?
It goes back to the truth.
What is it your truth?
If you try to,
if you try to avoid it,
you're going to get yourself in some,
you're going to be on antidepressants.
You're going to have to mask that,
that,
that true.
Just do what you're supposed to.
It is amazing that there's no one that's
ever come out with a really effective
guidebook of how to live life
in a successful direction
like no one could ever
tell you how to be successful.
What is successful to you is
not successful someone else,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Yeah,
but to teach you how to
manage the whole big package.
It's like the,
the,
the whole idea of managing the thoughts
in your mind is just missing from
school.
This did I have to just tell
you I'm laughing because when,
when people are self conscious,
like in my class,
this Guy Richard Lawson is acting teacher.
Somebody who was like,
whenever I like this guy,
this guy was like embarrassed
that he'd done something.
It's like,
I'm fine.
I'm just embarrassed by it
and my teacher goes like this.
He goes,
hey,
I fucked the pig.
I have.
I went,
what?
And he goes,
yeah,
I fucked the pig.
I'm writing about it right now.
You don't think that's embarrassing.
I'll tell you everything about myself.
I've fucked a pig when I was a kid.
How about that?
And everybody just stopped.
And they were like,
well,
you know what,
if you're going to admit that I can make,
I can admit fucking anything.
And it just liberates you when like
somebody who's a leader in a group goes,
hey guys,
guys,
in case you guys,
can everybody stop acting
like a fucking Puritan,
cause we're all pretty fucked up and,
and,
and I'm the most fucked up.
Bang.
You know?
So I don't know if there
was a point to that,
but,
which has kind of piggybacking
on what you're trying to say,
which is essentially,
you know,
just,
just whatever your fucking truth is,
just be honest with yourself and maybe
with a couple of your friends and then
just fucking follow that.
Okay.